yeah welcome to this video I and my self
is my opponent now sometimes when you
play chess you really feel that you are
you you you and yourself your faces the
Bonin it's an IM from Brazil yeah
playing this four nights variation with
these six I always believed that this
would be this is a good way to play for
white but it's not something I have any
deep knowledge about okay I think this
is real this is correct but I don't turn
I don't really know it in any detail mm
yeah
of course Bishop a 6 he's got Queen 85
yeah I don't want to exchange her name
yeah he is threatening Queen f2 quite
them quite quite an annoying threat may
be coming a 3 here preventing castling
well and intending Bishop e3 of course
it would be useful to really know the
the line here unfortunately i don't but
this is not bad i hope i'm also
threatening c5 which is a slightly
devious [ __ ] it's a ver SI fibers so
you can overlook that winning a piece
even on IG for something I've seen five
hmm i have c 5 he obviously didn't
listen to me what did i'm overlooked
something I think I'm just winning a
piece here
yeah cc5 is this a bit of a strange move
you can really overlook that black
resigns yeah it's just the bees to be
honest I i really like right here but I
think c5 may be as good play that
yourself and intend to use the bishop on
this good diagonal yeah this looks okay
I mean I thought I would go here let's
aim something like that and then maybe I
need to do something about Nigeria with
them yeah with a normal position White
has got the bishops with black has got
play in the center so probably it's um
it's a about equal okay quick game
thanks for watching